man darf auch keine häuser bauen kacka
kacka kacka alter krass krass krawalle
tnt falle o mein gott japan etf also der
einzige der ja irgendwie die ganze map
gerade eben mit fallen spielt es ja über
die boj schon einen wunderschönen guten
tag und herzkamp minecraft war oh hallo
mit con kraft oder seine letzte folge
nicht aufgenommen hat da habt ihr dann
wahrscheinlich gestern einfach so eine
erklärung video gesehen meinte zwar
wieder so witzig hat dann gesagt hat
heißt beschädigt doch selbst nicht
hochladen
forbes hat gesagt es ist keine gute
folge dass das kann man bei coli nicht
hochladen das kann selbst wird dann beim
kinos kommen das war einfach wirklich
keine gute folge ich bin halt ich bin
halt wirklich die ganze zeit einfach nur
um gelaufen war teilweise einfach dunkel
ich suche ja immer noch die welt von
debitor und rewe aber ich würde sagen
wenn es euch trotzdem
der letzten folge wir werden hier so
gedacht habe trotzdem fast passiert ist
keine was gucken da kamen die folge bei
mir kam ein kleines erklärungs video ja
bei mir bei mir aber nichts gesehen weil
es zu dunkel war ja aber es ist
irgendwas guckt einfach bei niemandem
unsere folgen
das ist so dass das optimum wir
versuchen ja auch wirklich mit unseren
erfolgen unter die 100 aufrufe grenze zu
fallen aber das stellt sich als
schwieriger heraus als wir gedacht
hätten am anfang des projekts ich finde
nicht dass ich möchte einfach noch ein
die ae&e das muss doch irgendwie machbar
sein
einen einzigen wirklich wieso finde ich
da gerade die die ja ich habe ich habe
eine eine wie nennt man das eine ader
gefunden eine diamanten ader und dann
sind da nur drei drin das ist doch echt
das ist unverschämt ist echt zum glück
lasse hier gerade die ganze zeit an
dieser verschiedenen wand her und ich
finde nicht diese base irgend ich weiß
dass die irgendwo auf seinem berg ist
mit normalem terrain also nicht mit
schnee oder wir ja irgendwie sowas ist
doch nicht mehr normal alten sind
pumpkins bittet die am ende ich habe
auch ich habe auch gar keinen gar keinen
sinn mehr hinterm einem strip mein
system ich einfach nur durch die gegend
und und schlagzeug weg das könnte könnte
vielleicht damit einspielen das ich
gerade nichts findet aber das wird noch
was leute ich hab das ich hab das ich
muss an das herz der diamanten glauben
die sonne geht und hat also ist doch
nicht wahr
auch man darf man sich eigentlich eher
in der folge aus merken dass ich mir zum
beispiel kurz schlafen lege nein ich
glaube nicht
ja aber das auge sieht in regel dazu
oder das ist auch nicht schlimm ich
glaube nicht aber warum bauen jetzt
nicht einschlafen die macht ein bisschen
nacht action
ja man sieht ja dann nicht sehr dann
auch nichts denn das ist ein paar tagen
bin ich eben hin
ich habe keine fackeln kannst du dich
nicht eben irgendwie den weg machen oder
so
du könntest auch einfach diamanten
suchen und neue helden ich habe glaub
ich keinen keine rolle dabei
ich hab keine rolle dabei tut mir tut
mir die menschen
die schweiz gehört schon ein bisschen
auf mich jetzt einfach fackeln das ist
ein bisschen was bio neuen update dazu
gekommen oder er halte auch so entstand
bei schick schick beim dann alles alles
geht komm ich muss doch irgendwo bitte
bitte bitte die us bitte bitte
minecraft man darf hier jeder alte alter
alter das ist egal ob mit einer basis
ich habe etwas gefunden weil ich ja an
fällt jedenfalls das könnte aber ist
dass ersten fällt auf jeden fall gesehen
hier ist auf jeden fall ein feld aber
die frage ist jetzt irgendwo noch okay
geht's hier war ich guck mal gehört okay
geht es weiter
oder nein aber jetzt ist das hier ja
hier gehts weiter das ist dass es nicht
von uns glaube ich das kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen
dort kann ich mir nicht vorstellen hat
es gebe etwa mal wieder geschafft eine
fremde basis zu finden der nächsten
episode freuen
das ist aber total komisch gebaut hier
so an sich also ich weiß nicht ich muss
ich aber hier geht es weiter hoch ist
das vielleicht das ist keine von uns das
kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
wir hätten wetten dass viel schöner wir
bauen ja auch immer total viel wenn man
richtig richtig schönes haus auch gebaut
und war aber leider nicht aufgenommen
wurde ja ihr habt werden das wären das
alles gemacht aber leider wird einfach
alle regeln verletzt und nicht auf man
darf auch keine häuser bauen
kg krake kakerlake alter krass krass
krasteva tnt falle o mein gott da van de
walle vielleicht was unser alte basis da
war nicht da waren fucking alter und ich
wieder ausgewichen
ich bin ja ausgewichen um ein fucking
gott alter was wir herzlich faktisch gar
den bekommen haben was für ein das war
das war so ein loch da das du glaubst
dass du auch nicht vorsichtig bist
ich bin rein gelaufen aber ich bin der
gott sei dank schnell genug weiter und
hätte auch direkt die spitze gehabt und
weiterzubauen alter dj wer auch immer
die dahin geschickt wenn das meine
kommen 2000 gebaut das interessiert mich
ist er bestimmt über libor also eine
einzige der ja irgendwie die ganze map
gerade eben mit fallen stück das er die
boj schon wieder was zum henker tnt
ich muss hier raus du musst auch wegen
der schallplatte treten damit irgendwas
passiert ist ihr gott oh gott
hier ist auch wichtig ich will mich
keiner mehr bewegen grad
mein gott walter vatter was machst du
denn immer ich habe noch nie in meinem
leben so albers in skelett ryder ich
kratze grad sonne warnt wenn ich
herunterfallen ist aus alter wie
unglaublich krass das einfach mal war
also wirklich wie wie da das dass unsere
alte basis ich bin ich bin zumindest
gleich oder aber direkt nebendran wir
sollten wir sollten sondern wieder
umziehen da ist nämlich da ist nämlich
irgendwer eindeutig das war das war
nicht wir hatten wir haben ja nie
normales fällt mit samen weißt du das
hatten wir ja toll also gebracht was ich
gerade gemacht habe es ist immer
unglaublich scheiße gewesen das was und
was soll wir machen
wir ziehen am ende der drei folgen
wieder um
okay okay dann zählt ganz bestimmt nicht
aber die tnt fahrer ist er bestimmt
nicht vor allem also wirklich ich laufe
da durch und ich dachte es ist vorbei
ja es war echt es war gut so ein
richtigen also wo ich mich besteht ich
habe mich ja beschwert eigentlich dass
die letzten folgen noch ein bisschen
langweilig waren im vergleich aber hey
das ist das ist ja das war ja also
unangenehmer geht es ja kaum krass krass
cars cars cars cars here das ist glaub
ich hier ist hier ist unsere alte basis
und da ist bestimmt auch schon wieder
das war eher die bei jetzt bestimmt auch
nie verlieren ich gehe mal rein
ganz langsam alter ey alter war das
unangenehm
ich mache ja etwas so riskante sprünge
so als 100 blöcken kommentiert dazu
einfach gar nichts ich bin ich bin auch
ich mich richtig ich bin richtig im
schock kartell krass krass weil ich
verstehe nicht wie du dann noch mal
daran laufen konnte weil du musst doch
eigentlich aufgehört dann nach oben
gegangen aber da hat einen tnt
wahrscheinlich irgendwie zu spät
gezündet oder ist nochmal nach gezündet
oder hat eine längere rektor und
schaltung oder wie auch immer jedenfalls
hat es noch eine halbe ewigkeit gedauert
bis es bis dann noch mal das explodiert
ist aber das war nicht in meiner nähe
also das hat keine gefahr dargestellt
lehmann krass aber wie wir wieder so
einfach wie wir das doch einfach
überlebt haben oder ich jetzt in dem
fall ja wir haben echt so viel glück ich
will noch einmal was der lava gefallen
nehmen in der letzten folge also in der
vorletzten folge
jetzt folgen war bei mir diese scheiß
erklärung skarke dann krass caspers
kreis nicht ob das ist unser eingang
hoffe ich mal hier
ja das ist auch sein glück dass unser
eingang ich habe alles wieder
ich brauche aber immer noch diamanten
beute also wir müssen unbedingt umziehen
weil er sie mit ihr in verbindung mit
einer anderen basis eigentlich könnte
man könnte man so sagen wenn ich mal nur
mit kurzen spitzhacke war es ein trip
hier gerade email holla die waldfee kann
auch nicht sein ich finde die ganze zeit
nicht diese scheiß basis ich laufe seit
zwei folgen dazu einfach schon um diese
scheiß map room
aber die muss er dann gleich kommt
wahrscheinlich ist einfach direkt bei
uns an der basis gewesen und ich bin
einfach eine falsche richtung gelaufen
ist ich kann ich nicht mehr da
verzaubern dafür brauche ich dann okay
gut dass solche verstanden von ea studio
ich bin gerade noch komplett in nicht zu
impfen
du hast gar die ganze zeit ich rede ich
rede von meinen traumata ich mache
einfach sprünge aus 1000 meter
entfernung nachgefragt wie konnten sie
leider normal reinlaufen dem 64 goldbaum
übrigens ja ich weiß nich gebraten er
macht diesen gold gold blöcke aber ich
weiß jetzt wie und wo schon äpfel äpfel
äpfel dass du wahrscheinlich
ob ich ein aber reicht eigentlich weil
wir auch nur einen opel machen werden
wenn wir nicht noch mehr gold finden im
moment fängt es bald wichtig dass du
immer das gold mitnimmst das geld was
groß es reicht aber glaube ich schon
moment das kurz gucken wir haben jetzt
hier 7
ja es wird wahrscheinlich reichen können
wenn du noch ein bisschen gold mit
brings dann wird das ausreichend führen
von gold natürlich praktisch goldbeck
immer hier rein
juli also lieber wenn du das war's
respekt ja dann genug goldberger glaub
ich glaube unbedingt respekt an dich und
deine familie ist wirklich great people
und das fand ich ziemlich stark gemacht
als das fast getötet richtig gut
ja also ich finde ich super dass du das
gemacht hast mich jung hat mich an mich
richtig gefreut hier halb halb zu
sterben steht vorher drauf aber das ist
echt du kriegst du ein krieg so ein
schock weil du der du denkst dir so man
denkt sich zwar immer man will action in
war aber es ist dann doch unangenehm
wenn was passiert wenn du denkst dir so
scheiße alles wofür ich jetzt die
letzten paar folgen aufgewendet habe und
gearbeitet hat könnte jetzt innerhalb
von von einer tierfalle quasi vorbei
sein
bei mir auch nicht auf einmal gold erst
ab auf einmal packt das alles rum und
auf einmal ist allah war da hatte ich
auch der todesanzeige weltkrieg auch cds
wirklich zu hastig woran liegt das wir
haben einfach glück bestimmt so ein
abgekartetes spiel und wirklichkeit ist
es hier so eine version von verstehen
sie spaß und wir beide sind die opfer
und das ist alles nur so ein fake dinge
die die tote sind immer nur gestellt
damit wir da und armut was passiert dann
irgendwas total böses womit wir niemals
gerechnet hätten in seiner crew wird auf
einmal
dem mann tötet uns einfach wichtig ist
völlig richtig dass wenn ich das finde
ich schön also unsere mitstreiter hier
wenn es wenn das ein spaß ist will ich
finde ich über dich voll bock drauf
macht man weiter macht mal macht mal
weiter mit verstehen sie spaß ja ach ja
das loch tatsächlich dachte ich gerade
kurze du hast ja schon öfters einfach
mal so geschrieben so der bay sondern
bekommt einfach gar kein schaden aber
jetzt alter das war auch das war jetzt
auch ich somit die grösste nahtod
erfahrung die ich glaube ich bisher in
barroso hatte lotto der fahrrad
erfahrung also alles andere ich war zwar
von den herzen her war ich schon weiter
weil darunter aber das war immer alles
er so geplänkel weil von den mops two
weisser wie sie sich verhalten bei sony
ist aber wenn also eine falle stellt und
weiß das ist von niemand gemacht er
weiter denken kann als zwei meter
schwierig sei es die ja sie auf jeden
fall angucken in deiner frage wo guckst
du dir das mal an und dann kriegst
bestimmt ein kleines tränchen dass die
wange herr abläuft weil schon das ist
bei gott hab ich bestimmt auch wirklich
einen einen richtig harten titel für für
diese episode ausgesucht und sich dem
chor unterstützt wir ein bisschen ich
suche die ganze zeit ich finde nichts
das sind
das ist gut dass du bereit wie weit bist
du eigentlich
ich bin so weit weg ich finde ja nie
wieder nach hause wir machen jetzt
einfach ab sofort getrennt ja denn damit
wäre echt schade eigentlich dass ich
mache das hier jetzt hier ist gold das
könnte sich die aus findet oder auch
einfach nicht weil mich irgendwie gar
was wirklich mal was ist das in jeder
folge haben wir bisher diamanten
gefunden und dann brauchen wir mal
wirklich ein
und das ist dann mitte juni
ich finde aber die ganze zuckerrohr
schon cool
das könnte es mal diamanten finden
konnte das finde ich super nova
an der oberfläche genauso wie damals in
hexe alter ist da viel zuckerrohr junge
ist das stark wie für sind stauden wie
viel stau den zug oder hast du ja ich
würde sagen wir steigen wirklich um auf
diese bücherregal taktik ich habe jetzt
schon 21 zuckerrohr ja dann macht das
einfach mal ganz ruhig ein bisschen
rumprobieren mit einem mittel verzaubern
um das zu optimieren vielleicht findest
du ja da noch irgendwelche besseren
methoden heraus mit dem wütender das
bisher ganz gut geklappt aber ich glaube
das habe ich bisher noch nicht bekommen
ist das hier schon wieder hallo bin ich
gehe kein risiko darstellt
ich schaue mir keine basis mehr an in
meinem leben du bist jetzt auch mal die
regionen waren einfach noch nicht so
viele leute es kann das kann sein ja
wort ich gerade auch sagen muss
wahrscheinlich eine region gelandet wo
bisher noch niemand groß seine seine fuß
staatlichkeit werber wenn jetzt an
unserem pyramide finden will oder so
schon wieder zum beispiel wieder
zuckerrohr zuletzt so eine pyramide aus
zuckerrohr ja so schön das wird auf
jeden fall meinen traum unglaublich
vertrauen von allen die heiße sommer
freundschafts büchern man sich damals
einer tragen hat ja ja ja freundschaft
zweier eingeschrieben größter traum ist
eine zuckerrohr pyramide zu finden in
minecraft und das auch zu nehmen als
youtuber ich verlauf mich hier noch
richtig dreck ja genau das war also auch
schon im kindergarten war das ein traum
oder das sollte klar
gerade da möchte minecraft let's play
offs machen
als konkreter auf youtube daneben
scanners aufnehmen werde ich sehe nur
fand nur wand und sand ich fand immer
noch mal weg und senkt das sieht er ich
habe mich verlaufen in meinem eigenen
höhlensystem habe ich dich ich glaube
eher wenig verlaufen außer ich bin
wieder in anderen basis und gleich
explodiert entfalle
was ich natürlich total toll fand also
ich bin da einfach inzwischen diesen
fällen auch von von dieser support das
auch richtig support dass sie total ins
am besten die ganze die ganze map
irgendwann mit tnt fallen zu punkten
aber das ist natürlich es ist ein
riesiges equipment also das ist ja jetzt
wieder wir reden da vielleicht ein
bisschen sowohl tüte fallen und das ist
natürlich ein riesen entschieden wir
allen dieser tnt fallen jemals
funktioniert ja für den bauer
das heißt wenn wenn wenn er halt mal
wirklich was was explodieren jemand
dadurch stirbt
ob die auf die rechte darf
das ist auch ein listen kommen wir
machen im dorf wer wir der hero zurück
das lässt das machen ja wieder im dorf
ist ja sowieso die vereinigung des über
grund hier mal wieder
ja es hat einfach keine miene das ist in
diesen traurig ich finde auch einfach
einen scheiß die asm man kommt schon
bitter
das ist doch einen einzigen werde ich
doch wohl noch schaffen dass man in
dieser episode zu finden das kann aber
nicht angehen dass ich davor am
laufenden band machen jetzt einfach hier
nochmal nochmal in strip mein system auf
design so schlimm ich habe mich in dem
in dem projekt ist es ist es ganz ganz
ganz grausam mit mir das weiß ich ja
aber leider kriegt weil die machen einen
wirklich nur ein herz schaden wenn sie
direkt vor einer fresse explodieren das
ist halt einfach nichts mehr aber
trotzdem das soll das gefühl im video
sturz gleich weil die dinger so laut
sind ja ich würde auch sagen wir enden
jetzt mal die folge ja ich habe immer
noch keinen diamanten gefunden wenn
solche sie sind 16 minuten 20 eine
bewertung da ich würde sagen ich suche
nächsten folge weiter die base cap
später gesehen sind in der nächsten
folge wieder reingeschaut